Nous allons découvrir dans cette exposition des fossiles exceptionnels de dinosaures à plumes !
Première chose : des dinosaures à plumes. Ce ne sont pas des gros dinosaures, ce sont des petits dinosaures,
mais qui nous racontent une très belle histoire puisque c’est celle, finalement, des oiseaux.
Alors, dans ces dinosaures, nous avons grosso modo 2 groupes : on a un groupe avec l’Anchiornis,
qui lui est à 150 - 160 millions d’années.
Et puis un deuxième groupe de dinosaures qui sont toujours des dinosaures à plumes qui sont
un petit peu plus récents à 120 - 125 millions d’années.
Alors l’Anchiornis c’est en quelque sorte la star de l’exposition, il occupe la place centrale.
L’Anchiornis, c’est vraiment la star de l’exposition, d’ailleurs quand le public va être devant cet Anchiornis,
il va se poser la question : suis-je devant un dinosaure ou suis-je devant un oiseau ?
La reconstitution qui en a été faite est absolument phénoménale sachant que, maintenant,
on est en mesure, par exemple, de déterminer la couleur même des plumes.
La reconstitution n’a pas été faite comme ça, dans le vent,
c’est véritablement basé sur des études scientifiques qui sont faites depuis pas longtemps.
La découverte de l’Anchiornis c’est 2009 et on est en mesure de proposer cette reconstitution
avec ces plumes blanches, ces plumes noires, cette houppette rouge.
Visuellement, la question posée : sommes-nous devant un dinosaure ou un oiseau ?
Il faut bien admettre aussi que les oiseaux sont bien des dinosaures.
On voit donc cette reconstitution, il y a aussi des sculptures en 3D et les vrais fossiles qui arrivent de Chine.
On voit aussi les fossiles de l’Anchiornis ?
J’invite vraiment le public à regarder ce fossile d’Anchiornis.
On voit très nettement toutes les plumes sur le fossile
dans un état de conservation exceptionnelle, liée à la condition de fossilisation,
c’est lié à des éruptions volcaniques extrêmement violentes,
extrêmement rapides, qui ensevelissent au fond des lacs ces animaux, avec d’autres faunes,
et qui ont permis cet état de conservation jusqu’à nous, 160 millions d’années après.
Et on découvre aussi dans l’exposition, des fossiles de dinosaures à plumes bien plus récents, notamment le Microraptor ?
Oui, Microraptor, Caudipteryx sont plus récents, sont à 120-125 millions d’années
et d’ailleurs dans ces gisements du Liaoning en Chine, on a aussi découvert d’autres types de dinosaures à plumes.
Ce qu’il faut savoir aussi, c’est qu'en même temps il y avait déjà des oiseaux
On voit aussi des fossiles d’oiseaux  dans l’exposition, de la même époque ?
De la même époque on est à 125 - 126 millions d’années et en même temps on a le Confusiusornis,
évidemment en Chine, on ne pouvait pas l’appeler autrement, l’oiseau de Confusius
qui, jusqu’à une date très récente, était le plus ancien oiseau archaïque connu
mais quand on le voit sur les plaques fossiles on a bien l’impression d’avoir des poulets un peu écrasés
mais ça ressemble tout à fait à des oiseaux et eux, par contre, avaient un vol battu.
C’est véritablement la grosse différence entre ces oiseaux archaïques et ces dinosaures à plumes.